pendant quinze jours vedette et
professionnels du cinéma vont se côtoyer
sur la croisette
la vitrine est brillamment illuminé et
tous ceux dont le métier consiste à
paraître devant les objectifs vont s'y
succéder avec complaisance mais ce qui
compte dans une soirée d'inauguration
c'est la fiche le plateau d'invités de
marque dont le dosage est
particulièrement délicat voici la
présidente du jury olivia de havilland
accompagné pour la circonstance de
charles boyer
car il ne suffit pas d'inviter une
vedette il faut aussi la convaincre
qu'elle ne sera pas éclipsé par une
concurrente peu de points de comparaison
par exemple entre l'aude milad sherin à
sheila et marie dubois
par contre la première sensation a été
créée par ce mannequin manifestants des
intentions plus que transparentes et
henri salvador toujours aussi grimacier
a permis à andré maurois président
d'honneur du jury d'effectuer une entrée
discrète dans la salle car la parade
devant les photographes et un exercice
de haute voltige qui n'a plus aucun
secret pour michel morgant la reine de
la soirée avec gina lollobrigida c'est
le film d'otto preminger in arms souhait
titre français première victoire qui a
ouvert hors compétition la série des
projections le désastre de pearl harbor
en est le point de départ la première
victoire navale américaine dans le
pacifique la conclusion mais ce film
remarquablement réalisé pèche par sa
trop longue durée 2 heures 40
et aussi par de nombreux épisodes sans
grand intérêt un très bon film dont le
scénario aurait gagné à être plus solide
avant la présentation de première
victoire monsieur louis jacquinot
ministre d'état devait déclarer ouvert
le 18e festival international du film de
cannes